february is heart month and locally the
children's heart foundation is dedicated
to funding research
in order to help babies who are born
with congenital heart defects live
longer and healthier lives so today
you're going to meet a young las vegas
boy who survived and is thriving
after receiving a heart transplant both
the children's heart center and the
foundation
help make the journey possible
[Music]
we all want one common goal and that's
to win
the only thing stronger than oscar
gamboa's will to win
is his will to survive
this was oscar four years ago after a
life-saving heart transplant
his mother kim was told to treat him for
asthma growing up
but years passed and he never got better
than the devastating diagnosis
your son has hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
which is a huge word and he had no idea
what it meant
and said that he's he's gonna need a
heart
transplant congenital heart defects or
chds are the most common type of birth
defect
each year nearly one out of a hundred
babies is born with some type of chd
oscars only got worse as he got older
it's just
thickening of the muscle of the heart dr
michael siccolo is a surgical specialist
for the children's heart center heart
transplants are such
valuable resources for a community you
have to
ration them to the youngest
and most fit you know
best suited candidates less than a
thousand pediatric heart transplants are
performed
worldwide every year luckily the family
discovered the children's heart
foundation
they provided a ton of emotional support
a ton
the group walked them through the
process and provided resources to
prepare for the procedure
which is only done out of state they
waited two years to get the call
it's almost like you turned numb because
you don't know
how to take your son's life and put it
into somebody's hands you literally
have to let go after a few
frightening setbacks and six months at
ucla
when you're given all that negative you
just try to look for those positives and
really that's kind of that's kind of how
i've gotten through it the family came
home and oscar began a new life
with a new heart how do you feel now
like what's it
been like for you i can take my dogs to
park i ride my bike you know to and from
wherever i need to go
it's really awesome just not having that
that worry and just having to live a
normal
like teenager life and that's all a
parent
could ask for too denise valdez 8 news
now
by the way those two are thick as
thieves they are really close uh the
donor family
really has a choice of whether or not
they want to connect with the person who
received their loved ones organs and
right now they're just not ready
but kim and oscar really hope to meet
them one day and learn about the person
who saved his life
kirsten great story thanks tony